you've got to be so proud of what you
achieved as a co-host on the real thank
you thank you and to see that chapter of
your life close recently yeah how's
everything going oh my gosh i honestly
feel like
with the real ending it was such a
celebration i mean the things that we
accomplished on the show i started
auditioning for the real
when i was 28 turning 29
we launched when i was 29 and i will be
39 in three months so a full decade so
that's a decade of my life giving my
opinion i look he was like people just
want me to shut up at this point so i
was ready for it not only that but
we're just so proud of what the show
accomplished just being able to be the
first
latina in daytime talk on english
language television was like
mind-blowing i'll never forget when they
came out and they're like this is the
press release that's going out today
with the launch of the show that you are
the first latina ever and i remember
panicking and being like i don't think
that's right like fact check please
backtrack like guys please don't make me
look stupid i don't want to be out here
tooting my own horn too too then they're
like oh girl you tried it you are not
the first stop claiming something that's
not true so i think now with the show
coming to an end genie and i were just
talking about the fact that like we
can't let
the concept of the show die does that
make sense we're super excited for the
next like who's gonna be the next to do
it who are gonna be the next faces of
daytime television that are representing
for women in color so were you ready to
say goodbye i know you guys i was i for
sure was i had just bought my house in
new york and it's kind of crazy because
we didn't know
if the reel was coming back after our
virtual season i literally did a whole
season from my mom's basement in new
york
and after that i was like things change
i think i changed
in that time i was like ugh i've missed
spending time with my family in new york
i feel like i've missed out on my nieces
growing up and little things and i
missed that and i wanted that so i went
and i bought a house
i ended up selling my house here and i
even shipped my cars across the country
and in that moment as the cars were
coming up the driveway i got the phone
call from telepictures and they were
like we're back in studio and i was like
i do want to ask you though because you
know how showbiz works yeah nothing ever
really dies everything has an
opportunity to be revived to live on a
different network
would you want to return to the real if
it was to be revived by somewhere else
it would have to be revived in a way
that still allows me to have a life in
new york we've talked about
family planning and my dreams of
becoming a mother i i think that it
would have to work in those parameters
for sure yeah what would the real 2.0 in
a perfect world look like for you it
would not be with me yeah i would love
to see new faces
the new format would not be with me and
i say that with love but i think there
even came a point where
the show that the reel started as and
how it evolved changed in so many ways
on our farewell episode we got to do
fake it or take it which was always my
favorite and jeannie leads that and we
get to run and be crazy and act wild and
i looked back at one of our producers
and i was like this is the show i was
hired for i was like this energy
is the show that i was i was hired to be
silly to be fun to be goofy to share our
own crazy personal stories embarrassing
moments to just kind of be an open book
and that's really who i've been for the
last 10 years but the reality is that
our world shifted
at some point and i think um
it was necessary
for us to talk about injustice and to
have political opinions and that sort of
thing but that definitely changed the
show
and even where we leaned a little bit
more on girl chat where it was more pop
culture
as much as like
yes pop culture matters it's not what
i'm a huge fan of like i would rather
sit and talk every day about myself i
don't necessarily love talking about
other people and i think that got
difficult towards the end it got really
difficult where i'd go home and i'd be
like did i
say the wrong thing did i say the right
thing or even more than that it's like
did i have the right to speak on this
you become a really whack co-host when
you look around and you go
guys i don't know
i think when i was younger i was like
yeah i have a right to and then i got
older and i was like oh [ __ ] you don't
know anything oh i'm like you don't have
the right to speak on certain things
well i think we could solve that problem
easily if there was to be an adrian talk
show is that something that i've
explored you would love that i would
love that i'd want to go back to daytime
i absolutely love daytime i'm a huge fan
of daytime tv but i'm more of a fan of
like old-school 90s
like david emily's coming back together
finding a long loss yes
this is the kind
richard bay hit me with the oink oink
oink i loved sally jesse raphael was
hands down my favorite bringing the
children that are disrespectful to their
parents so that i could let them have it
um i i loved those shows i loved ricky
lake i think that there was something
really special about that time so if i
could come back and recreate that sort
of show yeah sign me up
when you and i spoke in 2020 amanda had
just joined the cast of the real yeah
i've actually known amanda the longest
out of anybody else out of anyone on the
panel i've always loved who she is i've
loved how opinionated she is and that's
what we really what we love on the show
is having women that have strong
opinions and bring a different
perspective you had her back girl and
you proved yet again that you are such a
girl's girl and that you had her back i
watched the instagram live that you
amanda and jeannie did kind of seemed
like you guys got to a place of healing
after fans were really upset that amanda
was left out yeah of the farewell
episode we were like
this is wrong i said call amanda right
now like let's facetime her right now
like let's have the conversation with
her
and
that's where it begins like you can't
let somebody feel whack and not reach
out tell me why that was important to
you it was important to us to reach out
to amanda in the moment that we found
out we're like whoa whoa hold on a
second like she wasn't in it and it's
crazy because we were there and we
actually watched pieces of it on the
farewell show but me and jeannie calls
me she's like
are we just crying through that whole
thing that we didn't know like we didn't
notice we're so emotional wrong is wrong
and right is right
and i think that um
as you get older you're just like just
do the right thing doing the right thing
is actually a lot easier
than not
and in the moment we're like yo we just
want you to know that
that is not okay and that you absolutely
should have been a part of that
and that we love you and that we're here
for you and that we i think it's really
whack when somebody walks through
something like that alone
yeah well the thing that i took away
from watching it was that you and
jeannie were like friends first
just as human beings it's the right
thing to do
do you think amanda got closure after
that moment yeah and i think the crazy
thing is people also don't really
understand the behind the scenes of all
that goes into making a television show
and that people do have real friendships
outside of these shows and that it's
important to maintain those and that
that is way more important than anything
that you see on tv 100
did you care to ask what happened guys
why did we do this did you get in for
sure for sure for sure yeah we did all
of that you did all of that okay and
ultimately the thing that felt right was
to go and just calm down be like listen
it was wrong yeah okay and then as far
as your your former co-host like tamara
and and tamar were there ever
conversations about bringing the whole
squad back together if i'm being honest
i feel like
the whole week of the farewell season
was just like a blur but at the same
time i do know
that
there were all these parameters of like
coveted safety and like there was just a
lot going on jeannie had covid the last
week of filming we didn't even know if
she would be in studio so to add like a
bunch we were trying to keep it simple
give you guys a great hurrah this was
the show for the last 10 years nine
years eight eight seasons and just
enjoyed that is there still a group chat
i know that i see you guys in each
other's comments on instagram but is
there an og's group chat there is not an
og's group chat i don't think or not i
mean there was one i don't know if it's
still being used on our farewell episode
warner brothers actually brought us over
to
the lot where they have like this um a
marquee and they actually lit up on the
marquee and it was like warner brothers
wants to thank the real for eight
seasons like this whole thing
and in that moment
i got super emotional because i was like
oh can somebody please get tam on the
phone because for me it was like tam
should be here for like you know like it
was just like i'm mean she was such a
huge part of so many of those years and
so sure enough jeannie and i got her on
the phone and we all were just like
crying and it's funny because we
actually shot the last season in a
different on a different stage oh yeah
then you started yeah and i told jeannie
i said i'm actually really really
grateful
that when we said goodbye to stage 10 we
didn't know we were saying goodbye so
guess what me and jeanne did
we snuck back onto stage 10.
of course you can't make this up have
your your last piece your last oh no we
walked through they were filming a whole
other show i think it's
night court or something okay is now on
stage and we were so mad i don't know
who's on night court but we were so we
were like we walked up to our dressing
rooms and they had other people's names
i said who is this
this is this is wrong this is my room
you know it was all parisian themed with
a chandelier and i had a fireplace it
was all different and we just we walked
through and jeannie and i cried but then
we walked outside of the door and they
have the plaque there that says from
this year to this year the real is on
and it'll never go away in like this
beautiful bronze plaque that stays by
the and we're on there her name and
cement as it should be yes
[Music]